would just add that uh even if the
moderator isn't
technically counting the ballots when
the accu vote machines are being used
the moderator
will get involved perhaps in the hand
count of ballots certainly the
processing of absentee ballots
and maybe maybe making rulings on the
intent of the voter in
in ballots that some of the election
officials might have questions on when
tallying them
um the name badge certainly is is a
consideration
um and it's a
i don't have an answer i don't have an
answer
representative taurosian thank you madam
chair
um and again it it seems as though we
maybe don't have a clear solution
forward on this
but just to reiterate some of the
problems the um
you know in a town election some um any
selectmen that are up for reelection or
or anybody that's running
i would have to be up for re-election
they're not allowed to to
um in our town i know if this happens
everywhere
to participate in in work a shift during
the polls
when they were on the ballot so it seems
to
you know and then and that's for a good
reason so it seems like we should carry
it
a step further with the moderator
however in my district in one of my
towns
both the moderator and the assistant
moderator are both
current state reps so but so if you said
okay the moderator can't do it well
the assistant moderator is also a wrap
so you know
it's problematic i i too would like to
find a way forward on this but i don't
know that this
this part one of sb 83s is
representative as i
as i listen to uh more experienced you
know committee members discuss this i
guess
i'm my takeaway is that there's a
benefit to excluding moderators
um it eliminates a conflict of interest
it eliminates an unfair advantage and
maybe most important it eliminates the
perception of an unfair advantage
but there's also a cost in that a lot of
moderators
who also happen to be maybe candidates
for state rep
are among the most experienced election
officials that towns have
and and so we're just weighing this
benefit in the cost and and i'm trying
to get my mind around
you know how big a cost that is um and
anyone who can speak to that
you know i'd be grateful to hear from
um you know are there a lot of state
reps who are moderators are there a lot
of towns that would suffer if we
disallowed um state rep slash moderators
from
participating in the administration of
an election
how big is this cost and i don't i know
no one may be able to answer it but i'm
just that that's what i'm trying to
wrap my mind around as i'm weighing the
i see that deputy scanlon is still
online with us and i guess if
he would be willing i'd i'd like him to
answer
from as to your
office how often has this
issue been raised by members of the
public with concern
madam chair every election we hear
local election officials working the
polls
sometimes when they're running for the
same office but certainly
when they're running for an office other
than an election official
and uh you know i mean people feel
different ways about that and
and there are perception issues that are
involved
and you know when we train local
election officials we do everything we
can to make them aware
of uh you know those potential
perception issues that might be out
there while they're doing their job
and as has been discussed by the
committee this has been
a subject uh not just this year but
you know as representative bergeron said
for decades
and obviously there's been no resolution
to you know how to
uh easily address the concerns
the one thought i guess i would convey
to the committee
is that these individuals uh
that are serving as moderators or
supervisors of the checklist that
you know hold other positions um and
there are a number of state reps
uh that are also moderators uh currently
is that they are elected by the people
in their town or in their ward and those
positions are usually ones
that command respect um
the the officials are chosen based on
their
integrity and honesty and and
and the voters decision that they're
capable of doing the job
and and you know every example that i
can think of
that where a current state rep also
serves as a moderator
i think they're all excellent examples
running for an office but also doing
their job
as an election official and and even
though there's
you know this issue comes up but you
know every
every biennium uh we seem to get through
it and
you know i'm not aware of any real
scandals that are out there
that i can cite as examples of you know
this process going awry
because of conflicts beyond that you
know
i i don't have any answers on you know
how to
representative hamer do you have your
hand up
or do i have my cursor over your screen
i have
i think we understand the issue and it's
an issue representative
your head well i just i would propose
for people to consider that if it really
is a vexing question and it's been
it's been dogging people you know for 50
i i
rep our esteemed colleague
representative virgin for
five decades you know maybe rather than
pass the bill in its per current state
we should um
we should take this little one part of
it and study it uh just a little bit
longer and
and get a sense of how many people are
talking about how many times be affected
and and and just get a more precise
understanding of
of what the effects of this would be for
towns in the state
and i'm not sure that's the right course
all right i just um thank you for
raising that because it brings up two
points that are my understanding of
dealing with these omnibus bills
just so you know we cannot separate the
parts out
they remain in the final
vote on what will be sb
83 now amended by the senate
possibly amended by the house so
you're considering say part one is a
study
it needs to be contained an amendment
within the bill
and cannot be retained or dealt with
separately it it is part of the whole
package which is part of why i wanted to
have this work session
so that people understood when
amendments come forward you're dealing
with that
that part and you can make a motion to
amend the bill to delete a part
so you understand that's valid so you
can delete amend or leave a part in
we can't create a new bill
thank you madam chair i just wanted to
say you you've had a good historical
overview of the
current state of the situation regarding
this question which has been a question
as representative bergeron pointed out
for longer than i've been around
uh and i've always been one that's come
down on the side of you know that you
have to pick your poison
in terms of you know you either want to
run for state rep
or you want to do moderator um i concede
that
that representative bergeron and others
have raised
significant questions about about the
utility of that
in these circumstances um
but uh you know obviously if this were
not
a live issue it wouldn't be here and
but the only thing i could say about it
is i have no
uh answers any more than anyone else has
however
you know at some point you have to at
some point you have to fish or cut bait
as my grandfather used to
thank you all right any other committee
comments on part one
and chair we are on sb
83 representative growing yeah regarding
uh representative merhead's uh
suggestion
could there be an amendment just to make
section one a a study instead of
i it can but i think my reply is
how many times do you study an issue it
sounds like this has been
studied maybe not by virtue of a formal
separate committee but it's certainly
been discussed a lot
um and i think representative cody makes
a valid point maybe some people just
have to make a decision i know in my
community
the moderator has always just been the
moderator
um and we've had about three moderators
since the beginning of time
um and maybe that has something to do
with
how that election goes and that he's
handling ballots in my community once
you become moderator
you're there to you don't want to run
anymore or god has other plans for you
so and i know a lot of the communities
around me are like that
so
you know committee members can bring
what amendments they want forward but
um i just want everybody to understand
what the implications
are representative teroshian further
comment
yeah thank you madam chair no i i concur
with what you were just saying
um i mentioned one of my towns uh having
the assistant moderator and the
moderator both state reps
in my town my current moderator was a
state rep
but he takes very seriously um his job
as moderator to be completely impartial
to the point where he was a registered
republican he he no longer associates
with a
party he goes out of his way to to to
to make sure there's no indication or
[Music]
potential for there to be a conflict
interest and
so certainly you know people make that
choice maybe that's the
solution to with the future legislation
to come up with a way to maybe perhaps
have that kind of restriction
but it's getting back to part one it
seems to me the best thing we could do
with that is
to um is to i tell that portion of the
bill
in its current form just my opinion at
this point
all right i assume you're talking about
part one of representative friedas
it's been my ex that the experience of
the moderator is what keeps this
election running smoothly
and legally and i think it's rare i
don't know
i know somebody said there were two
representatives that are in my ward i
would prefer that
to be what it is that the moderator who
is running for another position
cannot touch in fact that happens i
cannot touch the ballots from the
counting then
so it's i i would leave it as it is
are you disclosing that you're a
moderator
no i'm not a moderator i don't think i
want to be okay
no um and because we have one that is
so good it's so experienced why would i
want to lose that
because he's running for something
how many days does the moderator serve
in that role as compared to the
representative
i just need a good mic and i have one
all right well so anything we pass will
be except for the good moderator and
representative friedas
district all right
all right part two of sb 83 is in
regards to the establishment of an
election
information portal um
there were a fair amount of discussion
on this there was some
question as to whether or not there
should have been a fiscal note
associated with it um and
uh the the end the
the end goal bill was that a
information portal would be
in place by january 1st of next year
representative tarouzian thanks again
madam chair
um yes and this was the one i i was
speaking to before when we were on
one of the other bills um because i
thought we had gone further ahead
and so in and you heard uh deputy
uh scanlon say that um that
there was some concern on the on the uh
on the date
uh the prime sponsor in this did
indicate that he
wouldn't have a problem if we chose to
push the date dates out
and i think almost certainly if we had
an interest in passing that we would
have to do that
but i believe i might have been one that
asked the question about the fiscal note
on that or the
what the cost would be and that was a
concern as well so
those are the two issues i see with with
that i don't disagree in concept with
the idea but whether or not
as it's drafted we can get there on this
i'm not sure
uh madam chair representative terezian
did you want to add something no i was
trying to i
i i tried to lower my hand i might have
hit it twice
no i'm all set all right representative
growing did you have something
yeah could uh deputy scanlon
comment on what an appropriate date
deputy scanlan thank you madam chair um
too optimistic to think that we might
have a portal
uh like this in place for the 22
election cycle but
is something that i think is certainly
doable for
2024 so you know if that's the time
frame that the committee would
want to look at i think that's certainly
something that we could
make happen
deputy scaling i guess i have a question
there was some question about whether
who who would actually be doing this at
least in my mind i have some notes to
that effect
um this directs that
your office with the department of
information technology
was there some financial
implications of this i would presume and
was there some
other department that maybe should have
or would be involved in this
as i call all right
deputy scandal technology the language
uh in the bill um suggests that we work
with the department of information
technology
when we're designing the portal um and
you know that's something we certainly
be happy to do
typically when there's ft project i'll
call it you know we we
establish the parameters um of what's
going to be requested
uh put it in the form of an rfp and then
have
some vendors uh you know submit their
proposals on
making the implementation of it happen
and
to do that obviously we have to rely on
some expertise
of i.t professionals which
um and that leads then to the question
of the fiscal note you know once we
do that uh you know we get bids in yeah
we have a better handle of how much
this is actually going to cost based on
does anybody know whether the current
general
house website has what we would consider
a true portal on it
because from what i know these are
pretty much static
pages that provide links to documents
or
i think that that's anybody i don't
believe we do have anything
um like a portal on the house
on the general court website
yeah i don't think we do either and i
raise that just because i know
um for other reasons i'm looking at
websites and i know what our
staffing is in our current technology
as compared to what other places might
have in regards to portals
and information and staff because i'll
tell you right now
we don't have it um so
i have a major concern with this and
then when
we put in a date of the end of next
session
you know not that i think this section
would be undone but i'm not sure
that that's a practice i want to get
into
because in two years from now and i
don't think this is an issue that it
would be
the next session could come in and say
be gone
and now you've directed people
on a path that maybe internally if they
had just done
would still be in place but by statute
we could potentially
all right well it sounds like
there's not general opposition to it but
there is some general at the
implementation and the date
okay section 3
of sb 83
where part 3 has to do with recount fees
it was
pretty straightforward it was presented
representative lane yeah sorry i can't
figure out how to raise my hand
um my comment was
and maybe it's just it's gonna cost
uh a senator more to
do a recount they're going to make
during their term
and it's going to count and it's going
to cost state rep almost the same amount
it i don't know it just kind of hit me
wrong but
i guess that's the price of
it just seems i don't know
odd are you are you talking about
section three with the
state senator and state representative
yes
but and i was just it just seemed
incongruent i mean
it's i mean we're basically public
servants we're making 100 bucks a year
representative barry i mean i i actually
have the the opposite feeling um
i i wished i wish they were higher
i think a lot of the i've participated
in a lot of recounts in the state
probably over 15 at this point including
municipal recounts
which are covered by this but um right
usually usually i probably in my
personal experience probably 70 percent
of the recounts i've participated in are
grossly unnecessary
um rarely ever with wyndham excluded
the current situation wyndham excluded
um do the results
change um and a lot of times these are
um
these are feel good exercises for the
losing candidate and by the way i've
worked for both the winning and the
losing candidates so
i understand what it's like to be on
both sides of that um
i i hear you about the state reps and
the state senators um
you know i i i look at the i look more
of the concern
with the statewide and congressional
districts
um and the cost associated with those
the secretary of state's office does an
excellent job on these recounts they
spend
a lot of money and staff on these
recounts um and one of these days
um we will have a statewide recount and
i have no idea what the cost will be but
it will be high
um you know in 2016 the u.s senate race
was decided by a little more than a
thousand votes
um and that would have been a perfectly
reasonable recount to ask for
um given the margin right um so i guess
i don't know i i raise all that to say
i'm kind of on the other side of that
but i have no intention of changing it
but
if somebody does change it to be higher
representative representative rosen
thank you thanks again i'm madam chair
yeah um
i was going to comment um um and
representative barry kind of hit on it
that
i mean if you look at the old uh fee
schedule if you want to call
that um what a rep
paid was less for a recount than um
a state senate race so it's always been
that way
um you know and i and i
to add to what um representative berry
said
his concern is a statewide and
congressional so
you know maybe a solution to that of
people concerned about you leave the fee
the same for
for the house and state senate maybe
even executive council and
and then the rest you do the increase i
i don't really have heartburn either way
other than i'm typically people that
know me know i i'm up
more often than not i vote against
things that are that are fee increases
because that's the way i am but um you
know i don't know what the cost of
what it costs to do a recount i know
there's a lot of volunteers if
we if we're woefully behind the cost
then we should increase it
again this was another section of the
bill that there was no fiscal note
we're already doing it so i'm assuming
the response would have been
no discernible change representative
growing
[Music]
thank you madam chair i agree with
representative barry on this
uh i think the even with the raised
fees i'm sure that even with the
increased fees it comes nowhere near the
cost
of the recount uh the point here
it seems is to the the greater the
margin the higher the cost
to discourage people from from doing a
um
you know asking for a recount if if
there's a larger margin
and i think the numbers are very
reasonable
it you know what with the state rep
candidate i agree that it's a
low paid position but i can't imagine
very many state reps spending less than
10 or 20 times these amounts on their
campaigns
i don't think the amount if they really
want to recount would
prevent them from doing it but it would
uh help to discourage spurious recounts
representative barry i mean i just want
to add
one more point about the state rep um
recount um not all state rep recounts
are created equal
um some districts are heads up you know
we're talking about less than a thousand
voters maybe 1200 voters
um in my district i have one of the
largest filterial seats
in terms of population in the state i've
got about i think 18 000 registered
voters
um so those recounts are different a
recount in dairy
where there's i believe there's almost
there's over eight reps in dairy now
um those multi-candidate recounts get
really really labor-intensive because
you're having to count you're not just
recounting
the the the first win the last winner
and the first loser right you're
recounting
everything in there um so if those those
state rep recounts can be a little
sneaky
okay somebody wants to make amendments
it sounds like in general there's not
if they're not overwhelming opposition
and there might be some
appetite for changing some of the fees
so make your amendments appropriately if
you're going to
[Music]
part 4 of sb 83 is relative to the
itemized statements
filed by political committees and
candidate on
what was used to submit to the secretary
of state
and ross berry was close to my heart on
this
in regards to saying that even font size
8 was not big enough
it should be 12. so
representative barry um to that uh
um madam chairman um i i did send an
amendment over to you from ols
i do have the uh fabled uh eight point
font a 12 point font amendment from ols
ready to go
um it's my intention with that amendment
that if we edit this
uh omnibus bill that i'll present it if
we don't
for some reason edit this ominous bill
which i think is an unlikely situation
i'll just sit on it
um i don't want to have to needlessly
send this bill back to the senate if
thank you representative terozian
thank you madam chair um so
i'm one that and i'm not alone
i'm more of a grassroots guy and i don't
have a team
when i run for state rep and i suspect
there's a lot of others and i do
file my um reports
um you know oftentimes i even fax them
and they're handwritten but you can read
them
and i don't want you know it's
problematic to me
it's just one more thing i have to do um
and others like me
now i have to you know spend more time
filing these things
if i have to have them all formatted on
on the computer and
and i'll go on record as being the
dumbest guy when it comes to computers
in the room and so that
you know the rest of it i'm fine with it
should they should be
legible but i don't want to be forced to
have to to
to do more work on these things because
what i do
submit is legible and it and then
they're handwritten and i do it myself
that's all so let other members of the
committee correct me i understand this
is a may that if you're doing it
electronically you have to do it in a
manner that's legible that that was the
intent it wasn't to force you to file it
electronically if you didn't want to
so somebody deputy scanlon you're on the
line could you uh
chime in as to whether that's your
understanding of this bill or not
uh yes ma'am chair my understanding is
just to make the forums
legible
but if people are doing hand written
they can continue to do that that's my
understanding
just want to make sure that thank you if
they are handwritten that they are also
legible
well thank you for the for the
clarification because i thought i heard
in testimony that this would force
everybody to have to do them
electronically
perhaps i'm on a misnomer there yeah
that was not my understanding
yes hi senator yes uh
representative terozin i just wanted to
point out that it's explicit
on line 22
page four for part four that
a candidate the political committee of a
candidate
or a candidate may file such candidates
required reports
as an email attachment a facsimile or
so i think that makes it very clear that
you can continue
to file on paper okay
so the new section the new section
on line twenty eight just base
thank you madame for comments on part
four
i'm not seeing any um so that sounds
like that i'm
i'm sorry representative sorry go ahead
sorry i need to look for your wave i
i i did it physically not virtually
um to representative quailey's point the
way i read that though is even with the
paper copy it says
provided that the font size
still would be required correct
but most people are going to write this
point but
so i think roman numeral 1 would still
apply but roman numeral 2 and 3
probably wouldn't is that a correct
reading is that how you would read that
that's my understanding i didn't
particularly
i don't think that the facsimile your
paper copy i think you can print out on
the form and that would technically be
electronic but
um i understood that i think i recall in
testimony that
you know some of the filings they would
make the font size purposely
small so that you couldn't read it as
printed and then you would have to
go to another you know medium so
i understood that you could still do
them hand written and this
really um dealt with if you look at the
title of
six here i am with my glasses and font
size 664 9a
this it specifically deals with the
and then the so i i sort of
saw it differently representative barry
um yeah
i'm looking at line 23 um it says
printed
so would there be a this is a good
question for all of our lawyers present
our attorneys um is there a difference
between written print printed
i i'm asking generally i i don't know
this is a this is
this one's uh this one's well well
i don't know they're probably i just
if somebody can hand write in eight
point font
that's you know at that point they
should be able to send it in
yeah well i would assume that written
refers to
graphologically and printed refers to
printed
that would be my um that would be my
belief but um
you know i've been wrong before it it
also says
on line 31 that
the candidate shall be responsible for
ensuring the report
is legible and it gives the secretary of
state or attorney general's office uh
to me the uh discretion to inform the
yeah right this gives them a little t
yeah i think reasonable people know when
now we're talking politics and craziness
representative sandler
uh yes ma'am i'm going to take off my
former lawyer hat here and just use a
obsessive wordsmith interpretation
but legible means legible someone's
handwriting might be more legible than
someone else's printing
and more legible than certain small
fonts that we get off of our
computers or a typewriter or what have
you the operative term
is legible if it isn't legible
everything else falls by the wayside
all right we're putting that in the
record representative sandler we're not
taking many notes today but
that's going in
[Music]
all right anybody else on part four
all right i'm not seeing anything so
we'll move on to part five this is the
last section
there is yeah
part four in regards to optional town
meeting procedures
um this dealt with the
representative sandler you're back on on
deck
um the prior years versus the prior
years
and i see that uh cordell johnstone from
nhma
is also with us who had commented on
this before
so i'm gonna defer to committee members
as to whether that needs anything
or not anybody think
that needs to change representative
i need you to unmute representatives
great thank you now you're on
thank you uh was the question whether
are we still on the legibility of this
uh
no no no we're on that now we're on the
the the issue of
a community being able to expend funds
before that fiscal year's budget
is approved and it's supposed to be at a
level
that is considered to be reasonable in
light of prior years budgets
and the issue came up in the word
i raised it i was the pain and i think i
was corrected as to the intent by
cordell johnstone
in regards to years on line five
year apostrophe yes as compared to
years with the plural apostrophe okay
years would be the plural you're right
if it's being compared to
a series of two or four or eight or
however many previous years
you would probably want to go back to
those years and determine what
percentage
of the uh votes were affected by it
if it says apostrophe s that that
means we're talking about a particular
year and its
ownership of the question that's going
on there
so we could talk about last year's
budget thank you or prior years plural
where we would have to probably go back
and do some kind of a statistical
analysis
right and my concern is because this
issue is generally raised by people who
are very suspicious of what their
municipal leaders are doing in
expenditures
and my concern is and cordell i hope
you're on
when you said prior years
to me that left it wide open to any
prior year
and so if you had big spending five
years ago but the prior year had been
pretty
lean you could argue that
a higher expenditure level until the
budget was approved was consistent with
a prior year budget five years ago
so i had thought that if you were going
to make it
if you're going to make a change it
should have been the prior
fiscal year's appropriations
not prior years so let me open that up
to comment representative growing
i i felt the same way madam chair
um and i think if we took out
the years where it's located and we read
this
in light of prior appropriations and
expenditures for the same purposes
during the same period
of the immediately prior fiscal period
and that would if the fiscal period is
more than one year
it would take care of that but it would
it would
clearly relate to the immediately prior
fiscal period
um i see that um mr johnstone from the
new
municipal association is with us i've
asked him if he if he can unmute um
if you want to comment please yeah
um hi and and thank you for um
inviting me uh i my point is simply
that the language ought to be clarified
uh because on line five it says the
current law says
in light of prior year apostrophe s
and you need i think it needs to be
clear that we're
either we're referring to just the last
year singular or we're referring to
a series of prior years plural
and the way it's written right now it's
it's unclear because it
it says prior year apostrophe s
if you want to refer to just one year
you should say
the prior year apostrophe
s if you want to refer to several you
should say
prior years s apostrophe
so so if you don't like changing year
apostrophe s to years
s apostrophe and i think what you want
to do is insert
the word the before prior
in light of the prior year
apostrophe s so it's clear that you're
just referring to last year
would it recorded i could speak up and
ask this question
school you know in my town my fiscal
year
corresponds to a calendar year so
there's no question about what you would
be referring to for a year
our school district encompasses two
calendar years but it's one fiscal
year sense to have the word
fiscal associated with year as suggested
by representative growing i i think it's
fine to include the word
the word fiscal and in fact the language
that he suggested
um i don't remember it exactly but it
sounded it sounded fine to me
my point is just simply simply clarify
whether you're referring to
one year one fiscal year or or several
fiscal years
and and i don't think i have a strong
opinion as to which it should be
it just ought to be clear one way or the
other
so if you wanted to say in light of the
prior
that would i think that would be fine
that would clarify it
thank you representative taurosian
thank you i had a question for mr
johnson i may
one of the questions was what was the
intent just the prior year or
or to be several prior years or years
that's
that was number one number two uh the
beginning of the fiscal year there's
some towns or
cities that start their fiscal year
prior to january 1st
most of the towns are on a calendar
fiscal year
but there are a handful that have a june
rather july 1
to june 30 fiscal year okay so it's a
follow-up
the id this is to address those towns
that started there
they say the 2021 budget prior to
january of 2021 then
this is the reason well the the main
reason
if you forget about the change on line
five the main reason for the change
on lines three and four is to
is to extend the benefit
that is currently available only to
towns
with a calendar fiscal year
to extend that to those that have
a june 30 fiscal year as well
because what happened last year
uh and it was very unusual obviously but
because of the pandemic there were some
towns
with a june 30 fiscal year that had to
postpone their town meeting
until july or august so they were
adopting their budget
after the fiscal year begins which they
don't ordinarily do
towns that are on a calendar fiscal year
always adopt their budget
after the after the fiscal year begins
the the fiscal year begins january 1 but
so thank you and the couple so yeah and
the couple of towns that i can think of
that have a meeting later than march
have their fiscal year beginning
july 1. so up until last year this was
not an
issue so this would clarify it
correct all right thank you
thank you any other questions or
comments
madam chair procedurally
sure um so
what would happen in a town and i
forgive me i have never
lived in a town i've lived in a city
what would happen in a town where you
did want to make a significant increase
in a portion of the budget how would you
go about doing that
you need to do it as part of your budget
this is
so if on and on cordell i'm jumping in
here correct me if i'm on
as a former selectman i might have
decide that i want to spend
10 times more than i did last year on my
road plan
okay everybody wants a new road and i
decide i ran on new roads i'm going to
give everybody a new road
my budget would have a huge
increase in my public works budget
for that plan what this
would mean is if the prior year i wasn't
spending at 10 times the rate right i'm
proposing the increase
i can only spend at the rate of the
prior year until the voters go
and approve the increase and then
whenever my meeting is then i can go out
and order my asphalt and spend at that
rate and if they don't approve it
i've kept myself at the prior year's
level so i'm not running into a
budget disaster by doing a huge
expenditure and then having the voters
say
hey we're not going to give you that
increase thank you cordell did i get
that
yes yes that's right if you want uh
basically
uh you need to you need to be careful
about your expenditures
between january 1 and the town meeting
uh and as the law says be consistent
with the prior year's expenditures
if you want to increase something
tenfold you
very well better wait until town meeting
when the voters approve the budget
and then you can spend whatever they
approve
thank you madam chair i i also think
it's important to put the
the word immediate in there if you're
really referring to the immediate past
year
somebody else brought that up i think
is that right with here or years so
i'm i'm hoping that representative
growing has volunteered to do an
amendment along the lines of the words
that he suggested i think it was he
representative okay
representative quailey thank you madam
chairman
uh i agree that clarification is really
needed and i think the
the the introduction of the word fiscal
is really important here
and and it is needed for the towns that
have their fiscal year
begin july 1st and i thought
representative groan's
amendment did a good job of clarifying
and it's important to clarify it because
it
it needs to be clear otherwise i'm also
a former select when i did one term here
in rindge
and things need to be very clear or the
possibility for conflict and dissension
rises very quickly so this needs this
fix needs to be done
thank you all right anybody else
okay i'm not seeing anything so we're
going to move on
to the last bill for work session the
last
senate bill for consideration by this
committee
that would be sb 89
um sb 89
would had a public hearing on april 23rd
this is a bill of omnibus
legislation relating to
the chief city chief election officer
dealing with photographs within the
guardrail
reprocessing of absentee ballots
establishing a committee and the duties
of the registrar of probate
representative bergeron when we get to
the part that you have an amendment can
you please
speak up um unmute yourself and speak up
because
of the computer that i'm on i'm not
going to be able to dual screen very
easily so
i'm going to need you to take the lead
on that amendment so part
one relative to the city chief
election officer this appeared to be
a change in label
um the term being used as a descriptor
anybody
okay not seeing any
i'm going to move on to part two
regarding taking up photographs within
i think we sort of discussed what the
purpose and
function of this one this is separate
from taking a picture of your own ballot
i'm not seeing any part three in regards
to
the pre-processing of absentee ballots
comments questions that's this is like
the calm before the storm
okay sure representative bergeron why
don't you go ahead with your amendment
okay thank you madam chair um
the intent as i understand it from the
sponsor in part
was to allow for cities and towns to be
able to reach out
to voters who were voting absentee whose
paperwork or affidavits weren't filled
out properly
and give them an opportunity to correct
those errors prior to the ballots being
counted on election day
um and that's a concept i think i would
hope that all of us support to try and
make it work
it was the approach to it the logistics
of it that i
had some concerns about um
there seemed to be some conflicting
language in the
uh original senate bill 89 as amended
for example in one section it was saying
that
if someone was voting in person the
clerk could
uh take a look at the affidavit make
sure it was
um filled out properly but at the same
time was saying in that section that the
clerk had to have a policy
providing a 24-hour notice that this be
done
it also provided that uh at five o'clock
the day after the the day before an
election
that the moderator would be processing
these
absentee ballot applications um
and you know presumably to find errors
that occurred in the affidavits
and then the clerk would have to contact
these people to
try and correct the paperwork of course
the problem with that is the night
before an election the election
officials are probably trying to set up
their polling places
and uh you know in practice once the
office is closed on that monday night
um there's no one going to be even if
the clerk can reach out to these people
there's not going to be anyone there to
accept the correction um and if that
we're telling them to go to the polls on
election day
to uh to vote in person the next day
um you know again you have the problem
well they're voting absentee because
they can't go to the polls
so the amendment that i was proposing
kind of took a look at uh
what we did during the covet uh
experiences last fall which would allow
the moderator to do the pre-processing
on certain days after the checklist has
been
certified by the supervisors of the
checklist
it eliminated the the night before which
is monday because
now the purpose is to try and find out
where there have been errors
that have occurred um it still directs
the town of city clerk
to try and reach out to these people to
see if we can get
their paperwork uh corrected
uh it also adds the word affidavit
envelope
and application because sometimes it's
not just the
envelope that's a problem it might be
the application itself
so we're asking the the moderator to
look at both of those
it's focusing on the moderator doing
this because under state laws the
moderator who ultimately has to make the
decision
as to whether or not a voter's paperwork
has been properly executed and the vote
should be counted
uh so even if the clerk was doing a lot
of preliminary work ultimately the
moderator has to go through all of those
envelopes
and make sure that the paperwork has
been properly executed
the uh other provision i
i put in there is and and representative
hamlin as well
is to say that if the moderator want to
hold sessions prior to the
certification the checklist they could
do so they just couldn't mark up the
checklist
until that session that occurs after
which is mandatory
that occurs after the uh checklist has
been posted
i think i've covered about the key
things i i mean i tried to
preserve the intent of senator gray's
proposal and try and
resolve some of the logistical problems
i saw with it
using as a model what was done with
house bill 1266
i'd like to think that that we were able
to accomplish that
and i guess if if you know other
committee members have any questions or
or input on this approach i would
certainly
committee members um is representative
mooney in
in lobby because i know she had a
conversation with her
clerk um and i i
wondered if she was available to share
it
i'll probably okay we can okay
yes i was contacted by my town's
moderator
she did have three very specific
issues with regard to the bill and i
think that
frankly representative erdogan's
amendment covers a couple of them
i'd like to really get them verbatim so
could you just give me one moment
to look for them
sure in the meantime representative
tarosian did you have a comment on this
section
yes um we heard in testimony on um
on page two i guess of this uh section
um line 17 that the town and city clerks
are the
designee shall open outer envelopes of
all assets ballots received prior to 5
pm on the day
prior to election day we heard testimony
from from
some town clerks one in particular was
that the town clerk from derry
who had a concern with that
um being required that it shall and that
the word may
may be better in that regard um and so i
didn't know if the
if representative bergeron's amendment
would address that section
or not uh if i may respond madam chair
sure representative bertrand um i had
that question of senator
gray during his testimony i said was it
your intent to make this mandatory
for all elections and he said yes um
so i kept in the language shell
and uh what i did in my amendment is
that
say after the checklist has been posted
or certified by the supervisors of the
checklist the moderators
shall hold a session to uh review these
uh you know open the elder envelopes and
review the affidavits
and uh i mean his as i understood it his
intent was to ensure
that election officials would try and uh
make corrections to any of the paperwork
that voters may have inadvertently made
errors to
to allow their votes to be cast on
election day so
thank you representative mooney do you
have your notes
thank you madam chair so the first one
is to allow
and that's in line with what
representative terozian just brought up
okay
number two is to allow
processing during the thursday through
saturday
prior to election not monday
and i see that very clearly in the
bergeron gambling amendment
age 1 16 through
19 and then
issue three allow challengers during
free
madam chair yet my amendment did not
address the issue of
of challenging um challenges occur
actually at the polls as the voter's
name is being announced
um and that would continue to be the
practice even with
those absentee ballots that were
pre-processed
based on again what i think senator
gray's intent was
i tried to preserve that intent in the
amendment
representative bergeron and i apologize
for not being able to
see your amendment um there was a
comment
during during our public hearing on
uh the second page of the bill of the
part
page three i think line 21 about the
moderator shall
then mark the chess list and there was
suggestion that that
be changed to the moderator or the
moderator's designee
does anybody recall that or think it's
material
if this section of the bill is going to
be changed
i i think i did say throughout my
amendment
the moderator or the moderators designee
okay great really does in the
pre-processing of absentee ballots
and and i if i may add during the public
hearing one of the members of the
committee asked
how many people are we really talking
about in trying to reach out
who may not have filled out the
affidavits or the paperwork properly
um my my best guess based on experience
is that
that is less than half of one percent
the uh of the absentee ballots received
the the real workload is the opening and
the reviewing of all the absentee
ballots not necessarily
thank you representative groan
thank you madam chair um i have a
question for representative bergeron
she's willing to take it
sure go ahead uh
do i understand that your amendment
would establish
certain days and possibly times for the
uh for the pre-processing
as opposed to sort of an open notice
process
uh yes the uh the pre-processing the
mandatory session
should not occur until the supervisors
of the checklist have
have certified uh the checklist for use
at the election and that usually
will occur seven to ten days before the
i looked at the dates actually the day
selected for house bill 1266
which was the um the covid
bill dealing with pre-processing of
absentee ballots
it specifically said thursday friday
saturday or monday
so in modeling that language i included
the words thursday friday or saturday
prior to the time established for
the date of the election so yes there
are specific days
it it really doesn't matter i suppose as
long as it occurs after the checklist
follow up go ahead representative
one of the uh concerns that i have
with the uh probably the main concern
with the pre-processing
is that when uh when a notice is given
um that that notice
unless somebody is necessarily really
watching for it they may not see it
election day is always the same tuesday
and people know that and i'm wondering
if we could specify
a certain like on say thursday and
friday at 10 o'clock
that 10 or 10 o'clock and following that
that this would be done so that we
establish a very
definitive time that is the same in all
towns and cities
that people then know okay this is this
is when the pre-processing is going to
be done and it becomes a habit
as opposed to something that can be
announced and
changed by every town and in any
situation
if with permission let me chime in on
that one
i do sort of like that but
i will tell you that the last september
election
that a after labor day the tuesday after
labor day
if you recall the primary um
we were setting up actually the thursday
night
and friday before the election because
that's when we had
staff available and could do it
and of course school wasn't really in
session um
so that's my i will tell you that's sort
of my concern
one of the the things about doing these
is your clerk slash moderators ability
to find volunteers
to come in and do this process
and if we handicap i don't want to say
handicap if we limit it to a particular
day you may end up with communities that
just say
we might like to do it but we there's i
can't get enough volunteers that day
or my moderator's not available or
um but i agree that it needs it there
needs to be
some parameters on when it occurs
if i may madam chair just to add yeah
house bill 1266 modeled some of what was
in
house bill 556 which i sponsored last
session to allow for pre-processing of
ballots
and during all the discussions and
committee public hearings
some of the issues you raised actually
were discussed that there should be
specific
days identified
thursday and friday became two of those
days that were identified
and then saturday was was added because
um
one of the senators felt well maybe this
should be done at the polling sites
and since so many polling sites are in
the schools it couldn't be done during
uh while school was in session and
therefore they threw in the saturday
so there was some consideration given to
try and identify
a very limited number of days when that
that could occur
um i don't know if there's really a
perfect solution for all communities as
representative griffin kind of alluded
to
okay thank you madam chair uh yes i just
wanted to reiterate that um
when the the clerk i mean it worked
really well in the
in the last election in the in the in
the covid
covert election um so when the clerk
announces that
the date of the pre-processing he or she
also has to announce the time
so the the clerk makes that very clear
that you know there's a date and time
of the where you know where the when the
pre-processing will occur in the
location
where it will occur so i don't think
that needs to be a statewide
you know specific rule but the town
clerks do know that they have to make it
very clear that
the date time and place of where the
pre-processing
will occur thank you
representative grohan one other
uh question on this a concern and that
is that if we
if we uh introduce may versus shell
and some towns do go through the
pre-processing and allow
voters to uh correct their application
and other towns choose not to then are
are we going to run into a situation of
of
uh that that voters and those in the in
the first group of towns
will have a an advantage over those in
the other towns and is the court going
i think that is a point raise and one of
the reasons that senator gray uh
used the word shell in his language
representative taurosian
thank you madam chair um since since
that
brought up about um there being an
inconsistency
this bill or this part of the bill has
has that built in
in that in essence it rewards
voters who vote early that have a chance
to have the information corrected
when those that don't on their absentee
ballots come in
after that date they don't have the
advantage of um
of having their missing signature an
incorrect name and so forth verified so
we already have that problem as as the
representative barry
um yes to build on what representative
trojan said i think there's
a big equal protection issue here um
specifically for those ballots that come
in late
um it's it you know we're the the kova
19 election 2020 is getting referenced
a lot um in which there was a surge of
absentee ballots
um you can most certainly make the
argument that when a third of the
electorate was voting with absentee
ballots
um that that this was necessary but i i
don't think going into 2022 that we're
going to see
that sort of turn out again and that
sort of
reliance on absentee ballots i also have
serious trepidations
about moving election day away from
election day
uh that has been a new hampshire
tradition
going back over a hundred years that
election day happens on election day and
we're not trying to stop anybody from
voting with an absentee that's their
right
certain people are not available at the
polls on that day and they have to cast
an absentee ballot
but we need to treat everybody equally
we need to treat everybody the same
and i believe we need to make sure that
we're keeping with the
new hampshire tradition of voting on
election day when possible
and that's why i want that's why i'm i'm
a big believer and as mitch
as much election activity needs to
happen on election day as is possible
i think in the future we are going to
have electronic poll books i think those
are going to be commonplace
in if we pass this this previous bill
probably in six years
that's going to dramatically reduce the
amount of staff or volunteers that are
needed on election day because the lines
are going to be much shorter there's no
there's not going to be a through d
anymore there's going to be four lines
you walk up you go to whatever
everyone's open and you vote
so i i think we're moving towards
addressing a lot of the problems that
pre-processing is attempting
to deal with already and
i i think we're kind of moving away from
that traditional new hampshire
experience of voting on election day
thank you other comments
so representative bergeron has his
amendment he's um the committee members
have it
if people have further changes or other
amendments
um they want to do i would suggest
either working
off of representative bergeron's
amendment with his amendment
okay the next section
all right the next section of sb 89
is part 4 which has to do with the
committee to study post-election audit
counting devices
um and some recount
discrepancy authorization investigation
to the attorney general's office
comments from committee members
representative bergeron
thank you madam chair my comments
pertain specifically to the
first section of part four which is on
page three starting with line 27
establishing a committee to study
post-election audit counting devices
uh last session senate bill 283
required that the secretary of state
conduct a study
of high-speed optical scan ballot
counting devices
to assess the feasibility of using such
equipment in a post-election audit
um that report was due november 1st
but given the challenges posed
during the last fall election by covet
and a lot of the preparations the
secretary of state had to make to
to address those issues at the polls uh
it wasn't released until march
23rd senator gray's bill
was actually introduced on january
26th prior to the secretary of state's
report
you know in looking at this section i
think basically senator gray
is asking to establish a special
committee to do what the secretary of
state has already done
so i'm not so sure there's this value in
creating
that committee at this time we have
retained
representative lang's bill in our
committee
to address the issues of post-election
audits
i'm thinking that perhaps that's really
all we need we don't need to establish
another committee
to uh do the work that was done last
session with senate bill 283 which by
the way
other comments on this part or
representative bergeron's comments that
terrific
representative taurosian thank you madam
chair
and uh question to represent bergeron
that senate bill he referenced that the
study has been completed was that
was that a similar type committee
um by that i mean did did it have um
um you know a couple members of the
senate uh three members from the house
and so forth or was it was it a standard
uh study commission as this proposes to
do
no it wasn't a study committee it simply
directed the secretary of state to uh
conduct a study as to the feasibility of
using these devices
as post for post-election audits so the
secretary of state was charged with uh
finding vendors to do it to conduct the
studies to use
uh ballots from previous elections to
see what kinds of results they were
i'd be happy to forward a copy of that
report the secretary of state's report
to all members of the committee
so that you could see what it entails
it's a 44-page report but 37 of the
pages
are the vendor's data which are attached
to deputy scanlan's
commentary i'd love to get a copy thank
you representative
thank you for emailing that to committee
members there was
a request for vendors to come and do a
trial run uh the secretary of state
conducted it up at the state archives
um there were two vendors i think that
were able to
become um another vendor was unable to
attend you might re it
occurred last fall whereas has been
referenced there were a lot of competing
interests going on for these
vendors that have these machines i had
the opportunity to be
there for part of it it was pretty
impressive
to watch um ballots which were um
put in huge stacks into
um high speed readers and how fast they
were processed
and that the machines could
pick up questions that were then
pulled out which allowed them whoever
the decision maker would have been
to sit at a machine and actually look
electronically at the ballot to make a
determination for example whether the
circle was
adequately filled in it was pretty
impressive
so i just sort of threw that out
and that was as representative bergeron
said as a result of senator gray's bill
other questions or comments from
committee members
on this section
okay uh madam chairman uh uh
representative growing
so i agree with uh senator uh with
representative bergeron
on on that section one of
section three but it seems to me that
section two we're on section four
excuse me section one i mean part four
okay yeah so excuse me
on section one of part four uh
asking for a study committee uh i agree
uh on that part that i think we should
just
uh deal with whatever we want to do with
this on representative lang's bill
but then if you go to line 15 on page
four and then
line um 35 on page four it seems that
those are
very different topics that aren't part
of the study committee if i'm reading it
correctly
um so those are
those really are it appears to me not
related to the
yes
and i i also recall that on
on the lion 30 where it starts on line
35 that madam chair you had
some concern about the about
uh the wording of the authority given to
the ballot law commission as being a bit
broad
um yes i did thank you for pointing that
out let's go back as senator
i mean representative growing points out
that representative bergeron's
comments in regards to the committee
dealt with only section one
of part four so i'm gonna move on to
and
that section deals with recaps
and i'm not i don't show that there was
much
question or comment on this section
does anybody have anything on this
changed
deputy scanlan i believe you're still on
the line if you could
speak as to the purpose and whether or
not
section two of part four has any
concerns for the secretary of state's
office since they
are in charge of recounts
yes thank you madam chair um
this portion of the bill
and section four is uh
is a reaction to uh what's happening
with uh wyndham right now and a
disparity between
the the count on election night and the
recount um
and you know the the
the the process uh took place as it's
doing the statute where there was
election night count
there was a recount that showed a large
disparity which
is which is unusual it's not unheard of
but it's unusual
um the bell law commission heard the
appeal
uh and they ruled that you know that
there was no
change in the outcome of the election
uh after the recount and and they
declared
uh the winners uh you know that were
chosen on the night of recount so
the question then became well you know
when when
all of the republican candidates uh jump
up roughly 300 votes
and the one democrat candidate went down
99 what was the reason for that and
deputy scanlon i don't deputy scanlon i
i didn't phrase my question well enough
for a moment
before we get to i think section three
the ballot law commission
i wanted to know whether the secretary
of state's office had any
comment or opinion on the exp expansion
in regards to the conduct of a recount
in section two
expanding the language the ballots cast
for such
office or question including votes cast
for the candidates or question on the
ballot
right in votes and not counted from over
votes or under votes language
because i didn't really i don't have any
notes indicating
that there was really much said about
this and i'm not sure what the problem
is it's trying to address
okay so the the law currently says that
the ballots
that are counted in a recount are the
ballots that were
cast in the election
um and it's as simple as that so when we
conduct a recount
we do not count the ballots
that were not used in the election
um and there are some that believe that
that uh we should account for the whole
universe of ballots that were sent to
the temple
for the election whether they were cast
or not
i mean it's up to the legislature to
decide whether we should go through the
exercise of counting
ballots that were not used or not it
will
require more time to do that and uh
we try to be as efficient as possible
during the recount so that's what that
part of the bill does
but deputy scale and if i can continue
this with the committee's indulgence
this doesn't talk about ballots this
talks about
votes so this means that this would
direct
to count votes that were legally not
well i'm looking if you're looking at on
page 4 lines 19 and 20.
is that is that what we're talking about
yes
yes uh including votes cast for the
candidates
or the question write-in votes
and we count those uh and not voted
resulting from over votes or undervotes
so that would be
an additional requirement that we do not
do now
where if let's say in in
if there's a town where you elect four
and the voter only cast votes for three
then we would have to count that no vote
in a no vote category
and then in addition to that if it was
vote for four
and the voter voted for five
we would also have to account for
the fact for that fifth vote um
and so there again that would require
additional time it's not something that
we do
right now if if they is under counted
we simply count the ballots that were
cast if the ballot was over voted
we simply count that ballot as no votes
being cast for any candidate
um yeah but it doesn't say ballot it
says
votes that's my concern my
concern here is this appears to be
directing counting those
votes not those ballots
so i understand that there's a concern
that
whether or not there's a check as to
whether the total amount of ballots that
a town receives an election
are the same as the amount of ballots
that might come back for recount
but to me that's very different than
votes and my concern is is that if we're
directing you
to count votes over voted
undervoted that were not part of the
tape totals plus
they can't recounts we are now having a
recount
with the fifth column so to speak total
votes possibly for a candidate
that were not counted legally
i understand what you're saying madam
chair and and i think that
that this language does do that it's
okay that's all i need that's all i
needed to hear okay
thank you any other questions from
all right i'm just i i will say flat out
i think that is a huge
mistake um
[Music]
and i will either or ask somebody else
to
to take this proposed language out
because i think
raising the possibility that we're going
to count
at an official recount votes that were
not part of the official election
results
creates a huge problem i don't have an
issue with ballots and maybe after the
audit
is done and we have an audit report
there will be a process to do that
that's clearly delineated
but i think allowing that possibility of
a result without
those guard rails so to speak
is incredibly
[Music]
dangerous as to confidence in election
results
all right so that was section two
section three deputy scanlan um
i think you had started to talk about
and
um is language
um that was somewhat referred to in
regards to
significant and unexplained discrepancy
as to what that
means and i have to tell you i i
don't know that i want a bill that has
anything related to the possibility of
could undermine public confidence
because
i think that's pretty broad too deputy
scanlan
thank you madam chair and i just follow
along the line that you were going
is that this is a reaction to what's
occurring in windham right now
um and i think that it would make sense
for that process to play out
uh before we start engaging in a
conversation
of you know what post uh
election and recount and bow law
commission appeals processes
should look at look like um the danger
here
is that you know we get away from from
a quick finality to the election and get
into a process that could be
really drawn out and um
you know i think that again we should
look at how the windham
situation plays out before we start
you know post election and recount
procedures
other members with comments on section 3
of sb 89 part
i'm not seeing any and i don't see
representative lane's hand
so part four of part
four of sb or section 4 of part 4 of sb
starts on page 5 of the bill i have is
printed
and it deals with the attorney general's
office with enforcement
my notes reflect that currently the
authority to seal or
unseal ballot boxes less rests with the
that this allows the attorney general to
unseal and resale seal the ballot boxes
um i this i guess maybe is for the
secretary of state or other lawyers on
the committee the attorney general's
office is usually
part of the enforcement arm of
election laws not the participant
and i'm wondering what impact having
them
physically involved in
ballot sorting counting
retaining issues does to that process
anybody have a comment i don't recall
hearing a lot about that
prior to today was that
i don't have any notes specifically
i i agree there i just i have i have
myself
highlighted the attorney general may
unseal and reseal
ballot boxes because that was apparently
a flag of a concern of mine
no no i haven't remarked as well but
maybe they did i don't know i have a
representative groin i i do recall i
i'm i'm not sure if uh senator gray
spoke about this at the hearing or if it
was a discussion i had with him
after the hearing but
the section four is an enabling
section for section three
as i understand it if you look at line
eight
through ten it says that the the
authority uh at the end of line eight
whenever the ballot law commission
requests an investigation be conducted
the attorney general
may steal or unseal and the
argument was this time
that the attorney general said he did
not have the authority to unseal and
reseal the ballot boxes
so this was to give him the authority if
the
uh election law commission said hey we
want this looked into
it gave the attorney general and rsa
76-c
the right to do that i believe that's
the intent that it's
it's really it's really the enabling
part for
section three thank you representative
groan i would point out that i would
argue it does not actually limit it to
that
it actually gives the attorney general
upon his
or her own motion so it is not
just authorizing the ballot law
commission to direct the attorney
general's office to do something
which i don't know that that's a policy
that we want to adopt it allows the
attorney general to do it
on their own motion again i'm not sure
that's
a policy we want to adopt attorney
excuse me
uh let me look here representative
tarosian
yeah i was just going to say madam chair
that um yeah it looks to
make um the process we went through with
senate bill 43
um if if this if this windham
problem were to crop up in the future um
without
this part of uh of senate bill 89
in place we'd have to go through if we
house so desired we'd have to go through
the same process again
to um to get those ballots unsealed this
in my opinion looks to attempt to
put in law the ability for the
attorney general's office to address
this in the future were to
come up no i don't know whether you know
if limits are not limits i'm
that that appears to me to be the reason
why that's in there
what i can tell that was
senator gray's intent uh for my
discussion with him that's what it looks
just to clarify it's my understanding
that the issue is
ballot boxes because there's specific
statutes in regard to the retention of
ballots and how that is handled
and that the attorney general's office
now and in fact has um
done books records papers about
documentary materials so
i mean it's sort of a mishmash is what i
would sort of say
i'm not sure i i understand the issue
that came up but
i'm not sure from a policy standpoint i
want the attorney general
whoever that might be to have the
ability to go get ballot boxes and
unseal them for whatever
they might think needs to be
investigated because as written does not
require
the ballot law commission to do the
direction
madam chair would you be okay with this
if we eliminated
no probably not because i think to be
honest with you
um you're taking the you're making a
major change
in the ballot law commission authority
um and i come back to what's a
significant and
i mean you know other people are not
raising a major
issue with this so i mean that's part of
having this
discussion so people can raise issues
that maybe they hadn't thought about or
maybe hanging out on the limb about to
fall off the branch all by themselves
well there's also the issue of the
discretion that
that language arguably grants to the
attorney general
okay i think those are concerns
does the secretary of state's office um
have a position that they want to
set forth in regards to this provision
thank you madam chair uh we have
concerns about this portion
of the bill uh as well for the you know
from the items that you mentioned um i i
will let the committee know that
that right now there is an opportunity
to unseal
ballot boxes if there are documents or
equipment
uh that were left in them after the
election
uh that are needed after the election
and that
process involves the secretary of state
going
to the town uh with witnesses in the
boxes to retrieve those items
uh and then seal them it's getting
specific to the attorney general
if there is a an investigation a
criminal investigation
that they are undertaking related to a
ballots or an election they do have the
opportunity to go to the court
and have the court grant an order that
would allow them to open those boxes for
that specific purpose
aside from that the boxes after election
and all appeals are over are sealed
and they are kept for the mandatory 22
months as required by federal law
after the election at which point they
are destroyed
town election ballots are kept for 60
days
thank you comments or questions from
committee members
of this section of sb 89.
okay i'm gonna move on to
section five which is
a relative to the duties of the
registrars of probate
this actually probably did get the most
public participation of all of the parts
of this bill
as i recall committee members
comments questions
representative teresian thank you madam
chair
um yeah well this this part five
certainly uh makes this a true omnibus
bill in that it doesn't have a lot to do
with election law as far as i can tell
but um but having said that um
it is in the new hampshire constitution
that each county have a
register of probate that does
the work that needs to be that's
required under probate
um and in 2011 we heard testimony that
that
responsibility got shifted to the
circuit court
area and um you know there's certainly
in my mind there's some merit to putting
it back where the constitution says it
should be
for one reason um like the rest of us in
the room i
took an oath to uphold the new hampshire
constitution and it seems like
this got put in the wrong place as far
as the constitution was concerned
but the other part is that we did also
hear testimony that
suggested and i've never been through
the probate process so i can't speak
um you know firsthand on that
um is less responsive than it may
have been in may and should be if it
were if the process was where
the constitution said it should be with
the
um the register of probate um
at the county level so that's my comment
i you know i don't i'm not sure
um you know the best way to handle this
i know there's problems with with money
um uh because this doesn't seem to fund
if if we decide that this is what we
should do
there is not money to fund that that um
activity
at the county level um and so that would
be something that would have to be
addressed
but anyway those are some of my thoughts
representative mcdonald thank you madam
chairman
um i've uh you know talked to a number
of people on this
on this issue and you know
this whole situation was changed
originally for a reason
working out effectively uh and i
understand it's in the constitution an
effort was made to take it out of the
constitution and we know how
constitutional amendments how
successful they usually are but to bring
this position back without a support
staff
without proper funding without any
training without even a clear place
as to where that person is going to be
working i don't think makes any sense at
all
i i guess my point on this section would
be you either want it in or you want it
out
i don't know that it appeared to be a
section that as
to the um
content of it itself that there was a
lot of wordsmithing
representative growing representative
that our constitution requires this and
i wasn't very excited about it in 2011
when we
i remember dealing with this when i was
in the senate but
at this point it seems to me kind of
like
um requiring us to reintroduce brakeman
that
would reside in the caboose of a train
that would have no function other than
to sit there
and i the the the responsibilities of
this
of this position have been given to the
court and
for the most part i think we're going to
have a person without a position
other questions or comments other than
that i request
permission to use putting somebody in
the caboose with no breaks
work in the future
okay
we will see it again madam chair no
matter what happens no matter what
happens
we will we will maybe not in election
law but
it will be seen again all right any
other
comments from community members all
right we've had a
uh i i think we've had a consensus
on a couple of sections of bills as to
changes that may need to be made
we've had a couple of volunteers for
amendments we've had somebody
already do an amendment um
and maybe persons are going to do other
amendments on on different parts
we will not be having an executive
session next week
um i'm not quite sure at this point when
it's going to be scheduled but it will
not be next week and part of the point
of that was so that if people wanted to
do further amendments
or have some more discussions about this
bill you have the ample
opportunity to before executive session
because i do anticipate we're going to
have to deal with
um probably series of amendments on
various parts of these bills
so i will let you know as soon as i've
got it figured out for executive session
i don't anticipate a need to meet as a
committee before the executive session
anybody else have any other business
they want to bring before the committee
this morning or this afternoon we did
make it into afternoon
i'm sure could i just ask that if people
are preparing amendments that they
distribute them as promptly as possible
yeah thank you and pam um if you're
still on
yes i just want to make it thank you
um i want to make it clear that as to
these
amendments we'd be dealing with them as
we would with amendments in
any bill if we're addressing a
particular part of a bill
and we have successive successive
amendments that they would essentially
be
overlaid as to the previous amendments
and then incorporated into
the final house bill as amended do i
have that process correct
or not well if i understood you
um yes i mean i think
if you have multiple amendments
um that are adopted to one of the
omnibus bills they would need to be
unified after the executive session into
a single amendment
um that would appear in the house
calendar they would not be
remain as separate amendments for the
individual parts of the omnibus they'd
all be
rolled into one but each individual
amendment that is worked on
you know it makes sense to to address
them
as a single part okay
that's what you're asking and i i would
ask that that any amendments that come
through um if people could include me on
the distribution list i'm not on the
committee distribution list but it would
be helpful if
if i had them so i can make sure they're
in the
the room for people to come in person on
the day of the exec
and also have them to to make that
combined amendment
thanks all right thank you
all right anybody else have any
questions or comments
all right i'm not seeing any thank you
everybody for
coming this morning early afternoon to
talk about these spills we'll get an
executive
session scheduled sometime in may
i will let you know as soon as i've got
my calendar figured out
enjoy the rest of your day everybody
thanks thank you madam chair members of